have you noticed that the YouTube
experience has been getting worse and
worse for free users this has been a
trend since basically the beginning of
YouTube but 2023 has been especially
pivotal it seems that every month Google
is trying a new strategy to maximize how
many ads viewers see for example in May
YouTube started blocking ad block
something that they had tolerated for
YouTube's entire history YouTube has
even gone as far as disabling video
playback for people using ad block and
and that's just the most obvious example
YouTube has also started experimenting
with 30second unskippable ads and
they're even moving to take some ad
control away from creators presumably to
optimize ad Impressions and maximize
revenue and it's not just YouTube either
it seems that every free service is
undergoing a similar Evolution discord's
free stream quality for example has
fallen substantially over the past
several years and don't even get me
started on free mobile games which which
are basically unplayable at this point
with all their ads the funny thing is
that you can even argue the same thing
about paid Services as well Netflix's
lowest tier for example now has ads now
I don't blame these platforms and I
can't speak for everyone but most of
these free platforms have offered
tremendous value for me over the years
whether it's entertainment education or
social connection so I think it's
completely fair for these platforms to
want to earn revenue for providing this
much value but it does make me question
the viability of Premium of course
premium is a great Avenue to break
barriers and make Services more
accessible but should premium really be
the default mode of monetization because
it seems that this just leads to the
same dead end every time these platforms
eventually get worse and worse for free
users until users either leave or end up
pain so join me as we take a look back
at the tech industry's obsession with
premium and why why the days of Premium
May finally be coming to an
end to understand how premium became so
popular we first have to take a look
back at what convinced the tech industry
about premium in the first place at
first glance you might be inclined to
think that the culprate is Google or
Facebook or the slowa VC backed money
burning startups but the corporate is
actually none other than Microsoft I'm a
of course talking about Windows and
Microsoft Office now this might be a bit
confusing as neither Windows nor office
was ever free but this is how fremium
used to work the official software
itself cost money but it was relatively
easy to get the software for free if you
wanted to Bill Gates was well aware of
this in fact he openly admitted it and
even sort of encouraged it we want them
to steal ours uh they sort of sort of
get addicted and then we somehow figure
out how to how to collect sometime in
the next uh in the next decade so you
know it's a great great place to be
involved in and it was a lot of fun
which was I guess the the key goal
eventually Microsoft did shift their
focus to monetizing users instead of
growing users this was primarily by
getting computer manufacturers as well
as schools and employers to pay for the
software and this turned out to be a
massive success Microsoft is now the
second largest company in the world and
sometimes even larger than Apple
companies like Google and Facebook as
well as a bunch of VCS saw this and
tried to replicate this formula in a
bunch of other niches but there was one
crucial difference between what
Microsoft did and what all of these
other companies did with Microsoft even
though users never feel the pain of
directly paying they are indeed directly
paying with new laptops and computers
for example the price of the software is
just directly built into the cost of the
machine itself with schools the cost of
the software is directly coming from the
tuition or local taxes and with
companies the cost of the software is
directly coming from the bottom line
which just means that all employees will
receive slightly smaller salaries lower
bonuses and you get the idea the bottom
line is that with Windows and Office
Microsoft has done a great job with
masking the cost but it's still the end
user that's paying for the software
directly with new age companies though
that's not the case which brings us into
the first major Pitfall of Premium the
friction of monetization the reason that
YouTube's monetization efforts feel so
significant is because there's so much
friction when it comes to indirectly
monetizing our use of the platform for
example let's say that YouTube on
average earns $4 per 1,000 views and
that the average view is worth 5 minutes
of watch time if you watch 1 hour of
YouTube per day you're averaging about
12 views per day or
4,380 views per year but all of this
translates to just
$17.52 worth of revenue for YouTube put
another way 365 hours of watch time is
not even worth 18 bucks for a
perspective subscribing to YouTube
premium from an iPhone costs more per
month AKA YouTube would have to increase
ads by a factor of 12 to make casual
users as lucrative as paid users due to
all the friction instead of directly
earning revenue from users YouTube is
having to wait for users to spend money
on advertisers products maybe 10% of
this Revenue gets put back into
marketing out of which 10% is actually
spent on YouTube marketing from there
YouTube has to give about 50% to
creators meaning that at the end of the
day YouTube is only left with Max 0.5%
of the total revenue that their free
users generate obviously this is not all
that great of a monetization strategy
but despite that the entire industry
would jump
in
whenever a given business Works other
entrepreneurs and VCS naturally try to
reverse engineer what made the business
so successful with companies like
Microsoft Google and Facebook the
answers seemed obvious it was obviously
the users that made these businesses so
successful in reality there was much
more to this than just that for example
a solid strategy to monetize these users
is also equally important
but many businesses and investors would
solely fixate on just the first half of
the equation users if they could just
dominate a given industry in terms of
market share they could worry about
collecting later and one of the primary
reasons that we got into this vicious
cycle of user growth over profits is due
to low interest rates with near zero
interest rates many investors simply
didn't know where to put their money to
earn solid returns so they slowly put
their money in Risk riskier and riskier
Investments leading to a startup boom I
mean just take a look at this graph
Global funding grew by 20x between 2006
and 2021 but the good news is that this
insanity is finally starting to slow
down as investors now have a new place
to put their money treasuries if you're
not familiar with treasury bills and
bonds it's basically a way to help fund
our government when you invest in
treasuries you're basically lending
money to the government to help fund
public projects and social programs
and in return for helping the government
fund these programs the government will
pay you back with interest of currently
5% this is where the biggest
corporations and investors have been
putting all of their cash and we wanted
to create an easy way for everyday
investors to do the exact same thing and
that's why we created our bond investing
platform Silo with Silo you can invest
in government and corporate bills and
bonds with the protection of $500,000 in
sipc insurance and $2.5 million in FD
Insurance all from the comfort of your
phone if that sounds enticing please
consider checking out Silo in the
description below but anyway this
strategy of user growth over profits
largely worked for much of the 2010s as
long as companies were able to show
phenomenal user growth month over month
and year over year their valuations
would keep increasing they would be able
to raise more money and everybody was
happy the only problem with this
strategy though is that if you pursue it
for long enough you event just run out
of users everyone who could possibly use
your app or service is already using it
for most tech companies this happened
right after Co hit with everyone stuck
at home these companies experienced a
final surge before achieving Market
saturation and now all of a sudden their
abysmal Revenue per user actually
matters luckily the best example of this
is WhatsApp there's no question that
WhatsApp is virtually ubiquitous with
over 2 billion active users but the same
cannot be said about their revenue in
fact WhatsApp doesn't even generate a
billion dollars in annual revenue
despite controlling a quarter of the
world population and a lot of this just
has to do with the fact that there is no
straightforward way to monetize a
messaging application and this brings us
into the next major Pitfall of Premium
which is that it trains these users to
expect these services for free WhatsApp
used to be free till yesterday so why
can't it just keep being free YouTube
used to allow ad block till yesterday so
why can't they just keep allowing it the
answer is that doing so is not only
expensive but quite unprofitable and the
only reason these companies put up with
it for so long is to hopefully convince
you that the given platform is of value
most users are aware of this but at the
same time they don't care either and I
mean why should they it's not their
responsibility to worry about whether
Google or meta is making money all that
matters to them is how much value
they're getting from a platform or
service and when that perceived value
goes down due to more ads or higher
subscription fees they're not really
going to be upset if anything it's these
company fault for setting the
expectation that these services are free
they went along with it because it was
beneficial in the short term in terms of
user growth but the same cannot be said
about the long term and that brings us
into the current crisis that much of
tech is facing the need to
monetize
[Music]
the bottom line is that the party is
over whether you're a startup that has
relied on VC funding or you're a tech
giant like Google the days of putting
user growth over profits are behind us
these companies are moving to monetize
as quickly as possible and they're
having to face all of the issues that
they had previously ignored like the
friction of indirectly monetizing users
and users unwillingness to suddenly pay
for things things that they have been
using for free for literally decades and
all of this is very much painting these
companies as the villain oh it's so
annoying that Netflix is Raising prices
and cracking down on password sharing
it's so annoying that YouTube is
blocking ad block and stuffing in more
ads and so on and so forth these
companies can of course continue to
experiment with their more creative
modes of monetization but honestly the
better solution is probably just to the
premium model the reality is that for
many of these platforms to truly be
viable with free users the user
experience would have to be degraded by
such a ridiculous amount that it makes
no sense let take YouTube for example
let's say YouTube wants to earn just $5
per user per month I think most of you
would agree that that's a reasonable
amount for YouTube to achieve this with
the average user who watches let's say 1
hour of YouTube per day though YouTube
would have have to show about 10 minutes
worth of ads every hour and that's
assuming that they earn $4 per 1,000
views in most niches that's not the case
meaning that YouTube would have to show
even more ads like 15 to 20 minutes per
hour I don't know about you but that
doesn't seem all that enticing to me and
I suspect that these companies are
coming to the exact same realization to
earn any sort of meaningful revenue from
free users they would basically have to
destroy the platform with ads or data
collection or payment for orderflow or
whatever New Age mode of monetization
they're using as such I suspect that the
main reason that YouTube is cracking
down so hard on ad block and pushing ads
is not to better monetize free users but
rather to Simply push free users to
become paid users as I think this will
become the new Norm the new Norm will
not be premium the new Norm will be paid
these platforms will of course keep
around their free versions but I suspect
that these will be more like light
versions that are watered down and
noticeably worse than the paid versions
this would obviously be a massive shift
from what we've been used to over the
past two decades but hopefully it'll be
for the better with users directly
paying for these platforms hopefully we
can move past more shady modes of
monetization like data collection and
payment for orderflow and things of that
nature or who knows maybe companies will
just end up doing both and things get
worse than ever are you fan of Premium
or would you rather pay for your
services comment that down below also it
seems that all of these money burning
startups who just focused on growth are
currently getting their funding pulled
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
[Music]
one